all right let's dig in to audience
questions first one is from Ken hey
David like you I switch between glasses
and contact lenses however I've been
increasingly considering going the LASIK
route have you ever thought about
undergoing LASIK surgery if so what has
kept you from taking the leap yeah I
have I'm nearsighted and I wear contact
lenses most of the time wear glasses
sometimes on the weekends or at night or
whenever I don't feel like wearing my
contacts my I don't have like super
serious nearsightedness so I think I'm
like a - 2.75 or something like that and
I have thought about getting LASIK for
me it's basically you know they the the
eye doctor typically says you shouldn't
do it until the progression of your
nearsightedness has stopped and I think
that means two years with no change I
believe and I usually have like a point
two five change every time I don't have
to do it again yeah I guess so I guess
it you want it to stabilize but the
thing is I believe and I don't know
exactly how this works I have quite a
few friends who are optometrists I
should ask them when you start to get
older the nearsightedness can improve as
you develop a need for not
farsightedness but something that would
cause the need for reading glasses I
don't remember but anyway I would
consider LASIK I'm not I'm a little
squeamish about the entire process I
know that for a while it was like with a
blade and then now there are no blade
LASIK or whatever but I'm a little spat
looks horrified right now the blade
thing I just couldn't do yeah there's a
blade involved laser spine or there was
and I just I'm a little bit squeamish
about it but I think I could do it cuz
friends have said they've had it done
and then they just go home they have a
you know like some kind of a mask
covering their eyes you go home you take
a two-hour nap you wake up and you've
got 20/20 vision or 2015 because the
inventor yeah I've heard in some cases
as well so yeah it's not um it's more
just that I don't know I I think I'm
waiting for the technology to improve
and I'm waiting to see if my like if
next time I go to the eye doctor I'm not
at a 3.0 then maybe I would ask about
LASIK yeah I have pretty bad eyesight
myself but I don't treat it in any way I
don't have glasses and I don't wear
contacts and it's interesting how I
don't really want to get contacts
because I'm squeamish about how the
whole process would go I'm shirtless to
it
but it's interesting that I'm too
squeamish for contacts and yet I'm
willing to do LASIK because I would do
this I thought when I had asked you
about your vision you said that you you
were fine that you had a perfect vision
or something also had me test reading
something from across the room oh yeah
you and your evil thing to do it just
fine and I couldn't see anything
yeah oh no it was obviously I didn't
believe you that you had perfect vision
but I thought you believed it no oh you
don't believe it either okay I'm like am
i driving less my driving test that you
have to take every five years yeah I
just guessed on the bottom line and I'd
miraculously passed I have no idea how
oh you're a danger to society oh yeah
yeah I know I didn't realize it was that
bad you you should really go and get get
glasses or something yeah I think I
think the audience would enjoy it you
can get some Warby Parker glasses
starting tomorrow I'll be on the show
like that yeah okay but yes someday I
will inquire about LASIK eye surgery